FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi, thank
you for joining us today.
SOPHIA AMORUSO:
Thanks for having me.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Of course.
So I've scribbled some
notes that I meticulously
made a while
annotating the book,
but the first
thing I want to ask
is, so you were the
founder, this was your baby,
Nasty Gal was your
company for years,
how did the idea of
writing a book come about?
I mean, was that
something you've always
wanted to do, is that something
somebody else had the idea for?
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Hi.
OK.
Let's see, so part of
my stories has a lot
to do with social media,
a lot of my stories
have a lot to do
with social media.
And on my personal social media,
which I didn't really have,
at least publicly, until
Instagram really came around,
I was getting a lot of
comments that were like,
I want to do what you did,
I want to work for you,
how did you do it?
Like I have an
eBay store, I want
to learn from what
you've done, whatever.
And so everything I've done
with Nasty Gal, social media,
a lot of it is about listening,
and it was very serendipitous.
So I moved to LA, I bought
a house, so it was cool,
and I needed an attorney.
And the only attorney
I'd really had
was someone who worked
on my will, which
is a kind of depressing
thing to do in your 20s.
And so I needed someone that
was like a general attorney that
could deal with contractors,
and an architect, or whatever.
I was going to
remodel this place.
And I got introduced
to someone who
was like, I didn't
know at the time,
they were an
entertainment attorney.
And so I had a
meeting with him, he
was like, listen I can
deal with contracts
for like, your
whatever, plumber,
but what else do you want to do?
Like do you want
a TV show, do you
want-- what do you want to do?
Nasty Gal's amazing, you
could do so much with this,
and I was like, I don't know,
a book seems really cool,
but I don't know.
And then he said, cool
I'll introduce you
to the head of the
literary department at WME,
I can't make anything
happen for you,
but all I can do is
make the introduction
and if something
happens then great.
And he did, and I had
a meeting with someone
who works for her, who is
now kind of like my fairy
godmother at WME.
And we had one
meeting and she said,
what would you want to do?
The obvious thing would be to
do a style book, a hardcover
coffee table book.
And I was like, I don't know,
I mean that's so expected.
And it's not because I wanted
to do something unexpected,
it's just because a business
book would be really fun.
And there's a lot
of stories that I
hadn't told about my experience
to reporters in the media,
because what am I going
to do, tell Forbes
that I was a dumpster diver?
Like what's the
headline going to be?
So it was cool to
tell my own story
and also I really
kind of set out
to write a book that
was, in some way,
like the gateway
drug to the business
section of the
bookstore, for someone
who may not be going there
yet, because I was that girl.
And I think there's
a lot to learn
in that part of the bookstore.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
that's interesting
that you say that that's
sort of the gateway drug
to like a book about
business or management,
because when you
see the cover it
doesn't look like a book
about business, right?
It's "#Girlboss," I mean, yeah,
it has the word boss in it,
but what made you
pick that title,
at what point did
you pick that title,
what does it mean
for you, and also,
how would you differentiate
a #Girlboss from a Nasty Gal.
Like if both have a
persona, are they the same
or are they different?
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Good questions.
So, I named Nasty Gal
after an album and a song
by a lady named
Bette Davis, and I
don't know, just
in that same vein,
really I'm not inventing names.
So there's a film, a
very little known film,
called "Girl Boss Guerrilla"
from the '70s that's
like a Japanese
female revenge flick,
and it's really
stylish, really good.
It's like girl gangs knife
fighting in the streets.
It's just so cool, and they
have a tattoo over their,
like, right boob or something.
So it's called "Girl
Boss Guerrilla,"
and I just loved the name, and
I was just like, "#Girlboss."
I don't know, it was never
called anything else,
there were no alternate
names, it was just kind of
really simple.
And then how do you
differentiate a Girl Boss
from a Nast Gal?
I think Nasty Gal
dresses girls to feel
like they can live the
life that they want
and achieve what they want,
and Girl Boss gives them,
hopefully, the tools to do it.
So I would say, the
ethos is very similar.
Nasty Gal is a fashion
brand, first and foremost,
and I think Girl Boss right now
is a book, [AUDIO OUT] cast.
This isn't working,
do you wanna switch?
FEMALE SPEAKER:Yeah,
let's switch.
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Hello.
But I think Girl Boss has the
potential to be a lot more.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You have a
foundation now and everything,
right?
Let's hear a little
more about that.
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Yeah, so
we launched the Girl Boss
foundation about a year ago,
and I just really wanted
to do something to give back
to girls who were starting
their own businesses,
and specifically
creative entrepreneurs,
I think, because it
was my experience
with photography that
got me kind of like,
oh that was really
fun about having an online
shop was the photography.
And it still is today,
even though I'm not
taking the pictures.
So to date we've given
away $75,000 in grants
to girls in like art,
music, fashion, design.
One girl makes these really
beautiful silk scarves,
and used the grant to like
rent some space in a showroom
and to make samples
of silk pajamas using
the same kind of
illustrations that she
prints onto her
scarves, and they're
really, really beautiful.
There's another grant recipient
who publishes novellas, so
short-form books.
Her company is called Novella
and she's really awesome.
So it's the start
to something that I
think will become a bigger
way that Girl Boss can tell
other people's stories
other than my own,
because I think even
hearing their stories
gives other people
perspective and confidence.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I mean I
think that's the biggest
appeal of your book,
and it was for me.
It certainly was
very inspiring for me
when I read the hardback
maybe a year ago.
And I think what's
interesting is
the whole trajectory from
quote unquote "dumpster
diving free-gan,"
sort of interested
in anarchy and sort of
going from job to job,
and then bam you're
a CEO and you
have this multimillion
dollar company,
and you're this
big success story.
And everybody thinks it's
an overnight success,
but that journey was definitely
not an immediate one.
SOPHIA AMORUSO: It's been
almost nine years since I
started selling stuff on eBay.
FEMALE SPEAKER: And so,
what I'm curious about
is, was there a
moment that showed
you, that demonstrated that,
you had sort of, quote unquote,
"made it."
Was there a moment
where you were like,
wow this is much bigger than
I ever thought it would be.
SOPHIA AMORUSO:
Yeah, absolutely.
I don't ever use the
term, I've made it,
and I get that a lot like,
when did you made it?
Making it, I think, is just,
like that's an everyday thing,
because if I thought
I'd made it I'd probably
look like the wrong way and
get hit by a bus or something,
be like, woo-whoo, phew.
You know like, don't turn
your back to the ocean.
But there was a
time, and there's
different moments over
the course of Nasty Gal's
trajectory, I think,
that were symbols
of that and other symbols of
like, holy shit this could all
fall apart, you know?
But I think the first one was
when I was in LA, like shopping
for vintage and
visiting friends,
drinking canned beer
in someones backyard,
and my auctions were closing,
which is just so cool.
You get all these
e-mails and the auctions
go crazy at the last
minute, because people think
they're going to like sneak
in and get a great deal,
but they actually just drive
prices up because all it takes
is two people that are
willing to spend $100 more.
And you're like,
whoa like it went up
$100 in the last three seconds.
So, I think it was
probably 2007--
I mean it was only on eBay
for like a year and a half--
that my auctions were
closing and it was one week's
worth of auctions and
it was like $2,500
of stuff, which I probably paid
like, who knows in total, $100
for.
Who knows what my
total cost was.
But it was just like, wow I'm
drinking a beer with friends
and I just made $2,500.
I don't even know if I'd ever
made that in a month at a job
at that point in my life,
so that was pretty exciting.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's almost like
it's so surreal because it's
an ordinary moment where
you're drinking beer,
instead of this
big glitzy moment.
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Yeah, I mean
so many exciting moments
happen on our
phones now, I guess,
and that was the case for me.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So tell us
more about your current role.
So you were the CEO, now you
are the executive chairman.
You are, of course,
always the founder
and you carry and embody
so much of the brand
to so many people
who admire the brand,
but what's your current role?
How has that evolved
and do you still
have as much
creative input as you
did in the choices and the
direction the brand is moving?
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Yeah.
So you know, when you found a
company, you're also the CEO.
I mean I was a CEO of a one
person company at one point,
technically.
I was also, as soon as we
incorporated on LegalZoom,
I guess I was the executive
chair or the president,
and the secretary, and
all of those things.
And, you know, CEO
was never a title
that I was like, I'm going
to start an eBay store,
I can't wait to
have the CEO title
and have people call me that.
It just doesn't really matter
to me because what I've built
is what matters.
What I get to do
everyday matters.
So I've always been
the executive chairman,
I'm still the
executive chairman.
What does that mean?
I mean I own most
of the company,
technically I
control the company,
and I have as much
creative input as I want.
One thing we're spending
a lot of time on right
now is creating tools
for our creative team,
for anyone that
touches the brand
to understand what the brand is,
to know how to use the brand,
what the parameters
are, where you can play.
But over the course
of the last--
I mean since I've had a team
that are making decisions
on Nasty Gal's behalf, whether
it's writing email copy,
social media copy, taking
a photo for social media,
or taking a photo that's
going to go on the home page,
all of those things have to
go through some sort of brand
filter.
And when all you have is
conversations about that, one,
you find yourself having
the same conversation
over and over, and two, it
feels like a personal thing,
so it feels like my opinion
versus your opinion,
or someone's opinion versus
someone else's opinion
about what's right
for the brand,
rather than this is what
it is, it lives here,
let me self-reflect before
anyone-- a tool basically.
So it makes things
more objective,
and that's something we're
doing a lot of work on,
is getting this kind
of like brand bible,
I guess, to get out of my head
the things that make Nasty
Gal tick, so that other
people can do a great job
and aren't getting emails from
me at midnight being like,
what is this insane copy,
like what does this even mean?
I don't send emails that
sound exactly like that,
but you know, there's a lot of,
when a company becomes sizable,
and the brand-- you know, I
think if our brand was more
focused, if we had a singular
product, if we were Blue Bottle
Coffee, keeping the brand
in line would be simpler.
I'm not saying it's easy,
or it's easy for them.
We have so many products that
we write so much copy for,
we take so many pictures and
send out so many e-mail blasts,
and post on social media
so often that it's almost
like the volume is
hard, but also Nasty Gal
has a very specific
voice, which isn't
as easy to nail as the voice
of maybe some other brands.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Do you feel like
there have ever been moments
where you felt pressured?
It's not working.
SOPHIA AMORUSO:
Here, let's just--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hello.
Hello.
OK.
Do you feel like they
have ever been moments
where you felt that there was
some pressure on Nasty Gal
to conform to whatever was the
sexiest sort of mass market
trend at the time and then
you might have-- have there
been any moments where you took
a direction that didn't fit
feel like it was faithful
to the actual brand?
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Yes, but
I would say our intent
and the execution-- so in
intent, no in execution, yes.
So when there's a lot of
different people fulfilling
the task at hand-- we have
something internally that we
call "fuxury," which is kind of
like the word fuck and luxury
together, and it's almost like
another word for aspirational
or any word you could
think of, but it's
kind of like our
product architecture,
we just use it to refer
to something internally.
But, because it sounds like
luxury, at a certain point--
and we had a fair
amount of turnover
in this period in
merchandising, so there's that.
So there's the
people that did know,
and there's the people who
are new and still trying
to figure it out, and
you never really know
who placed the order
for whatever it is.
But the last year
or so there's been
a fair amount of
pricey stuff coming
through, beautiful
stuff, but I think,
we want to have quality product,
and to really stand behind
that, our price should migrate
a teeny bit, like a little bit,
but I think it migrated faster
than we had anticipated.
And that's something that takes,
I mean, the lead time's long,
reacting takes time, and
that affects your business.
And that's definitely-- I
don't want to turn off the girl
who's looking for
a $58-$68 dress,
we have to have
something for her.
And there's been
moments in the last year
that it looks like we're over
her or something, which is not
the case, you know?
FEMALE SPEAKER: So let's take
it back to the earlier days,
around the time you
started the eBay store.
Right before that,
you had a lot of jobs
and you detail
those in the book.
You worked at the art
school checking IDs,
and you worked at Subway, and
all these different things,
and then Nasty Gal
happened, and it stuck.
So one thing I am
curious about is, do you
have sort of like
a system, a way
that you know now, after having
been through all those choices,
of knowing when to quit and
when to keep grinding or keep
hustling?
How do you make that
decision about anything
big about Nasty
Gal or otherwise?
SOPHIA AMORUSO: It's tough
because I worked really hard,
but a lot of what's worked
for me has also been somewhat
of a path-of-least-resistance
model,
and that can work when you're
doing everything or when
you're young, when the
future's wide open,
or when you don't have a team
that needs a strategy that is
looking to you for leadership.
So to operate a company
like Nasty Gal today,
that just doesn't really work.
There are opportunities
within that pop up,
but that's a tough one.
I think I'm loyal
to what I've built,
so I want to see it through.
I'm loyal to the
people who work for me
and the girl who's been shopping
at Nasty Gal, because that's
the only reason I have a life,
and a home, and some poodles,
and whatever.
So as much as I can I'll do
right by all of those people,
but it's a lot of
different groups,
and there's a
feeling of, I guess,
social debt that I have kind
of endlessly where I can never
be all the places I wish I
was, or with all the people
I wish I could spend
time with, because I
know they would like my time
or my feedback or my input.
And that's a challenging thing.
I think I'm kind
of rambling now.
I want to answer your question.
There was a point, and this was
before I chose to step up out
of the CEO role
where my job became
just meeting after
meeting after meeting
and there wasn't a
lot of creativity.
And today, you know, I'm
bringing really great
collaboration's into the
business or spending time
on things like this brand book
and other things that will give
the company kind of like
legs for the future,
but don't make me just kind of
want to bang my head against
a wall, because there's people
that are a lot more skilled
and experienced than I am at
getting grown-ups with a ton
of work experience to do what
they say they're going to do
and not give you excuses
for why it didn't.
It's just like, I don't
want to tell someone
that they're lying if they
say that this snafu happened
and that's why it
didn't get done on time,
like I'm not going
to-- whatever,
I'm just really
babbling now, but it's
just like, I don't know, it's
like the tough versus nurture.
But like, you need to
nurture people for them
to be better, for them to
know what the task at hand is.
There's like such
an art to leadership
and it's going to take me a
really long time to learn,
and that was one thing that
I knew the learning curve was
just way too high
for me on and there
are things that
I'm way better at,
so I think when you feel like,
when you wake up in the morning
and you're not having
fun, that's probably
time to change something.
So I guess, a heuristic.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I
don't know if I'm
pronouncing that, heuristic.
So you talk about
exulting the details
and how that was a big part of
the success of the early eBay
store.
You would take the pictures and
make sure the silhouettes were
right, you would make sure the
descriptions were evocative,
and it just seems
like you tirelessly
put all this work into making
every single listing fantastic.
Now when a company grows
to over 400 people,
to hundreds of
millions in revenue,
and when you're not talking
to the customer directly
all the time like you used
to, or seeing those orders
and MySpace comments
come in, how
do you make sure that those
details are still exalted?
What do you do to maintain
that kind of a culture
and that kind of
attention to detail?
SOPHIA AMORUSO: I think
that's really hard
and I think that's something
we're still figuring out,
because that has to become
systematic at a certain point.
It starts with hiring
people who care,
who take pride in what they
do, who are open to feedback
and want to learn, and who
want to tweak out on their work
rather than show up
and just like, OK
put the jacket on the
model, what time is it,
I'm leaving now, you know?
But the brand work
that we're doing,
like having tools for
people to understand what
a successful subject
line in an email
is versus a call
to action, I mean
it's not as drilled
down as that yet.
But I think ultimately
you have to really define
what success looks like
for people for them
to be successful in fulfilling
on the brand's promise.
And some companies do
it better than others.
And I would say it's a
work in progress for us.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So it seems
like, when you've started out,
a lot of things were sort
of based on instinct or gut.
You kind of just paid
attention to the customer,
you listened to
what she wanted, you
made sure to pay
attention to every detail.
There were also,
I'm guessing, a lot
of things that didn't
come so naturally,
like with learning how to be a
leader of hundreds of people.
So, looking back, what would
you tell 22-year-old Sophia
who's just started
this store and you
have no idea that
it's become going
to become what it has become?
What would you tell
her to, sort of-- yeah,
I mean, what lessons
would you give her?
SOPHIA AMORUSO: I
would say focus.
So I enjoy having
a lot of ideas,
but when you have a business
plan, which I never did,
it forces you to say, OK this
is what we're here to do.
And I'm the kind of person
that's like, oh my god,
opportunity, cool, the
book was successful?
Now what?
What am I going to
do with Girl Boss?
There's more people
coming out for a paperback
than there was when the book
originally was published,
so that means something.
So cool, is it a conference?
I don't know!
So that's just what I do, but
when you have a team that's
trying to just accomplish
the task at hand,
it's not super helpful,
it's probably distracting.
So it's I don't know, it's
something that, I don't know.
Focus, focus, and
then, yeah, just
have that, what's the
center of the universe?
For Nasty Gal it's like,
we could become a content
business, we could do all these
things that will probably--
it's like just
getting the job done
that we have today is
a challenge enough.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So apparently
it's time for Q and A.
Does anybody in the
audience have a question?
We have a mic to pass around.
Sasha Arijanto.
AUDIENCE: I'll abuse my
power to ask a question.
I don't know if this even works.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Did you turn it on?
AUDIENCE: It is working?
OK cool.
I think you're so cool and I
have worn so many Nasty Gal
outfits to really important
life events, so thank you.
A lot of us are
probably hoping one day
to start our own companies,
or be in that early stage
process of a company, and when
you were in the early days,
it seems so important
to make sure you're
working with the right people.
How do you know who was going
to come to work and be excited,
or who was going to come
to work and just want
to look cool and
then peace out early?
And do you have any advice
for working with friends,
like yes, or like keep
your friends close,
but work with just
professionals?
SOPHIA AMORUSO: I think
you know pretty quickly
if someone's going to show up
and do more than what the job
description, or at least
at the bare minimum
the job description, or if
they just want to look cool.
I don't know, once you accept
that, the people around them
will think that
that's the standard,
so you kind of have to cut that
out pretty quickly if that's
the case.
But, in terms of assessing
that before you hire someone,
I mean asking them for ideas,
like if you don't have ideas,
then you're probably not going
to go beyond whatever you're
told to do, and it makes more
work for the people around you
or for that kind of
person when they're like,
I'm done doing what you
told me to do now what?
And you're like, oh my god,
there's so many things to do,
I don't know.
Does that make sense?
And then what was
the second question?
AUDIENCE: Like choosing
to work with friends.
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Oh friends.
AUDIENCE: It should be just
be only a work relationship.
SOPHIA AMORUSO: I would
say keep your friends
your friends and
your team your team.
I mean, maybe-- I don't
have a co-founder,
it seems really
cool because you can
have one person doing
PR and the other person
running the company or
whatever, but in terms
of hiring your
friends it's tough.
I've told myself
that, for the friends
I have worked at Nasty Gal,
I will work with them--
it's been more successful when
they report to someone who
reports to me, or reports to
someone who reports to someone
who reports to me, so
that I'm not negotiating
their future with them.
But even when that is the case
there's still awkward moments.
And when your friend tells
you that they're stressed out,
you take it, I'm
like I'm like, oh no.
It's just more
personal because you
care about their
well-- I mean I care
about everyone in my company's
wellbeing-- they're probably
just not going to be like, oh
my god I've been-- I don't know,
does that make sense?
Yeah, just it's a
different conversation when
you go to dinner with a friend
who doesn't work for you,
and it's so much nicer, I think,
to keep it that way sometimes.
Anyone else?
FEMALE SPEAKER: You can
just ask the question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO: That doesn't
happen as much anymore.
It used to happen.
I think a certain
amount of humility
is good it's just like,
OK, I get it, you know?
But going out your way to prove
that you're smart or belong
is kind of awkward.
Often it's just being
like cool and curious,
and if someone doesn't
know why you're
standing in front of them
and you think they should.
I mean, the art
of conversation is
kind of like a lubricant for
getting to maybe the more
important things or
talking about what
you want to talk about.
And also, I don't know, people
love to be asked for advice.
So if it's someone who is
in a position of power,
I don't know, those people
often-- I don't know,
a lot of people aren't
ballsy enough to just say
like, hey, I know you did
this, I have a question.
And it's really flattering
for those people,
and it also gives them
a break from themselves,
which is kind of a gift.
But I would say just act as if.
It's like, if you don't
belong in the room
because you're the
only girl in the room,
or someone doesn't
take you seriously
because they've never
heard of your company,
or whatever it is, it doesn't
mean run around acting cocky.
It's just, if you see
yourself as the person that
is not that thing, that's
probably what you'll project.
That's like what the
world will see you as,
so there's a little
bit of whatever-ness
that you just kind of
have to keep close,
if that makes any sense.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Thanks.
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Totally.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO: So the
question is, for the video
camera, what's different about
my journey because I'm a woman.
I named the book "#Girlboss."
What's happened, what's
transpired in my life
because I'm a woman.
AUDIENCE: Like why wasn't
it called Good Entrepreneur?
SOPHIA AMORUSO:
Good Entrepreneur,
would that be a good book name?
I mean, you know there's a-- OK
I'm going to adjust my skirt,
because it's way too short to
be sitting and kind of lean.
There we go, maybe.
What's different?
Nothing, really.
I think a book called "Boss"
probably would've sold as well.
And I think it's a
cool sounding hashtag.
And you know the
book isn't really
about being a girl at all.
Have you read the book?
I really don't talk about being
a girl almost all in the book,
but I think there's a lot of
girls that need someone that's
familiar to hear their stories.
I think it like predigests
the lessons in a way
that, when we style something
on a model, when she looks
like she's going somewhere
and she has a handbag,
and she has a certain
attitude and she doesn't just
look like a stale person,
you can see yourself
in those clothes.
So I think we all learn a
little better when things
are put in context for us.
And I think that's
what Girl Boss has
done for a lot of girls who
want to be entrepreneurs,
or who just want a
voice from someone
who had no more money
than they probably
do, if they can
afford the book, when
they started their business.
There's a lot of
women talking to women
who have really great educations
and really great platforms,
but a lot of women
talking to women
stuff I think is a
really stale looking.
It just feels a little,
just like really serious,
and it also can be very
expensive to attend some
of these conferences and stuff.
It's like $6,500 to go talk
about being women, which
is cool, that's great for
a certain kind of woman,
but there's the
rest of us, and I
think that's why Girl
Boss really resonated.
But as far as my career becoming
what it is because I'm a woman,
I think I've been celebrated
more because I'm a woman,
for sure.
I mean I do with that what I
can, because that's what I do.
And I think, maybe because
I wore vintage clothing,
and I wasn't like a
fashion freak or anything,
but I wore vintage clothing
and the brand is for girls,
and I think I get them
because maybe I am a girl.
And that would be
the only advantage
other than having a laptop
and a digital camera
and living in California
and all these other things.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Yeah,
so it's her question is
about personal style and how
do I stay true to my style.
And I think my style has
changed, along with Nasty Gal,
there's a lot of stuff that
I haven't worn that we've
curated, but I would
say I've always
been wearing leather
jackets, I've always
been wearing black boots.
My hair got short, then
my hair got kind of long.
But it's how you carry
yourself, so someone
could wear the same
outfit and look--
and you wouldn't
even really recognize
that it's the same
outfit sometimes.
I think it's more about who you
show up as than what you wear.
But, let's see what's changed?
I like to say that LA gave me
legs in more ways than one.
So when I lived in San
Francisco, and in the East Bay,
it was just like
pants all the time.
You were a skirt it
blows up over your head.
You have bangs,
they blow back past
your-- give you a big forehead.
And then you move to LA and the
weather's amazing all the time,
and the sun is beating
through your window,
and you can't go outside in like
polyester high-waisted pants,
it's just disgusting.
It's like it's like a UTI
waiting to happen or something.
So that's cool,
but also, if you're
going to wear something short,
it forces you to exercise, too.
So then it's like this
kind of domino effect
of positive benefits to
wearing a skirt instead
of pants I guess.
OK, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO:
Oh my god if you--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO: No,
that's really interesting.
So the questions about like
tracing the #girlboss hashtag
on, mostly on Instagram
is where I look, and it's
kind of run off with itself.
It's become a part
of the lexicon.
So there's like
Beachbody, which is
like a company which has like
girl boss things that they do.
My dad's like, I know
someone who's-- will you talk
at their thing?
And I'm like, what is this?
He's like, they
call it girl boss.
It's like whatever, I need
to get a trademark attorney
on this.
No, I don't want to do that.
I don't want to turn
people off and be like,
no you can't make a coffee
mug with Girl Boss on it.
But, the hashtag #girlboss
has like twice as many
impressions on Instagram as
the #nastygal which is crazy.
And the book's, you
know-- Nasty Gal is
nine years old and a
commercial-- and yeah,
it's not a book, so
it's really interesting.
But there's like--
everyone interprets
it a little differently.
Why can I not find-- OK, sorry.
You're right there.
Everyone interprets it
a little differently,
so you'll see stuff,
like a quote from my book
next to a quote that I
really disagree with.
Like someone took a
picture of me sneaking out
of like the Instagram,
the like square thing.
It was a photo I posted
because we were in New
York at their headquarters.
And then they put
copy over that said
like, when you lurk
your man's Instagram
to make sure he's
still miserable,
or something like that,
and it's just like, whoa.
Just like, the whole
empowerment thing, people
just like run away with, and it
just means, like, I'm a bitch.
Just like, no, that's
not the idea here,
but it's pretty
funny, it's cool.
And if it makes anyone feel a
little more confident when they
leave the house in the morning,
I am super happy about it,
so yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Yeah, do
you look really familiar?
Britney?
Oh my god, hi, how are you?
This is Britney, she was one
of our first interns ever,
in Berkeley.
Yeah, you work here now?
That's so cool.
Congratulations.
You.
That' so cool.
You look different,
you look like-- did
you have braces then?
Sorry, you just look
a little different,
and there's light coming
from behind your head.
What's the podcast?
You can subscribe to it on
iTunes and other places.
I'm not really sure
how distribution works,
but it's in partnership
with Slate and Panoply,
which is their podcast thing.
And it's going to be
a weekly podcast where
I interview really cool women.
We're recording with-- what?
Oh, your face, sorry.
I thought I said
something weird.
This is Krista.
I'm just going to
interview really cool women
and hopefully have funny, fun,
inspiring conversations that
aren't super dry
about their life.
OK motherhood let's talk
about that, OK are you
an entrepreneur or an
actor or a musician?
How does that work?
What do you have to
wake up and do every day
that you absolutely hate doing?
Or I'll ask a celebrity, do
you use public restrooms?
I'm really excited
about that one.
Yeah, it's just
going to be hopefully
fun and educational and,
yeah, Girl Boss Radio.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO:
Brands I look up to.
I think Google is
pretty awesome.
I feel like I should
just stand in this skirt.
Google.
Blue Bottle is one.
I think Luxury does
it really well.
I really love Dior.
What else?
I mean, companies
like Red Bull that
have turned their brand
into a symbol of a lifestyle
beyond a drink.
Like, that's amazing,
that's really
kind of transformational to
turn a really simple product
into something that means
something much greater.
So any brand that's
doing that I would say.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO: Yeah, so
the Girl Boss Foundation.
The question is, the
Girl Boss Foundation,
what's going to happen?
Are you just giving grants away?
Are you helping people, too?
Because you blow through
money and maybe learn nothing.
That happens.
Ideally, yes.
Right now no one works for
the Girl Boss Foundation,
so it's really, it's pretty
kind of bare bones in terms
of the operation of it.
Long term, absolutely.
And, even just giving
these girls a platform.
So we had an event in
Santa Monica at our store
with one of the grant
recipients, Nouvella,
Deena Drewis, who does Nouvella
Books, and she was in front
of like, I don't know,
a couple-hundred girls
being interviewed
by the West Coast
editor of Vanity Fair,
which is just something
that wouldn't happen otherwise.
So I think exposure,
that part is easy,
because we can tag
team that in some ways,
but I do think mentorship
is really important,
and long term I think
that will be a part of it.
We need to assemble maybe
a board of advisors,
and who knows, it could
be a venture fund.
Like I have no idea, I just
get excited about ideas.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SOPHIA AMORUSO: So
what have we learned
from the physical stores?
We get real time
feedback on the products,
like this thing's falling
apart, or this zipper is just--
the factory-- we can't
inspect-- we don't, we
can-- some people do,
it's very expensive
to inspect every single thing.
So there's things that come out
in the process of people trying
stuff on, or this
runs large or small,
or people are loving this.
I think it allows us to see
opportunities a little sooner.
I mean we're learning that our
girl loves to shop in person.
She loves to shop
online, but there's
a level of service in our
stores that I'm really proud of.
That's like a higher level.
I mean you can't go
into an Urban Outfitters
and have someone do much
more than kind of roll
their eyes at you.
So I'm really proud that
we have friendly girls who
engage, who are there.
Yeah, they're like,
hi, how are you.
They're not hounding
you, but I do
think that at our
price point it's
hard to find like, I don't
know, a boutique experience.
Melrose especially is like that.
What else are we learning
from retail stores?
That we want more of
them, that will take time.
I think that's it for now.
Cool.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sophia,
thank you so much for coming.
Let's give her a
round of applause.